[Music]
so in other mike tyson news unrelated to
his uh flight where he was socking the
dude uh
there's a recent state law that went
into play that prohibits mike tyson from
being able to sell his gummies in
colorado what oh the gummies that are
holyfield ears
he's got these cannabis gummies that are
shaped like holyfield ears that's so
funny that's tight
that's hilarious what were they called
again
um i thought it was a little tight oh
there's an actual like holyfield related
name
i think so do you think holyfield signed
off on this our ears i think our ears
power here
yeah they're so cool now that's where
ears are power ears
mic bites
they look like pieces of beef drip yeah
they look like little ear yeah i love
hearing them talk like holyfield and
mike tyson because it's like now that
they're just chill like older dudes
homies and then they're like man i was
so scared of you dude
[Laughter]
he was so scared like he was just like
dude you're [ __ ] killing everyone but
i knew that like i was beating everyone
too but no one was giving me like any of
the props that i deserved because you
just had this guy that's just knocking
people out she was like i knew i had to
fight you at one point but i was scared
shitless
edit their [ __ ] i do some of their clips
and thumbnails and stuff for their for
mike tyson's hot boxing do you really
never did you never ask can i meet mike
tyson no
you should what i would love to meet him
because like there you don't want to
bother him though so because he like
yeah
i'm about eight feet away
it's like i'm going through a different
company so they're hiring you're going
wow that's cool oh you had a vietnamese
[Laughter]
holyfield mike tyson had a very very
famous fight in which iconic yeah
holyfield kind of like headbutted him
during the fight so as retaliation mike
tyson bit a chunk of his ear off
actually more than once in the fight he
bit his ear one time didn't take the
chunk off and then the second time he
did it
really good piece
so then now mike tyson has a gummy
company for cannabis gummies and the
gums are shaped like ears yeah they're
called microbiota
colorado why do you think it can't be
sold only in colorado is it because of
the the the they have really different
laws for weed and [ __ ] because they
first started that stuff they do
actually yeah they have different laws
for marijuana edibles yeah what do you
what do you think what specifically
prohibits that
don't do that with your eyebrows you
can't have edibles
wait you can have other edibles yeah you
can have you can have edibles but then
basically there's a colorado law that
prohibits edibles to be shaped like
humans animals or fruit
because they think it'll attract
children's interest ears
like fruit snacks it counts that's the
sad thing is you know even though it's
like really made as like an insider joke
for the you know so you can't you can't
sell gummy bears in the state of
colorado no you can't get cannabis
shaped like a bear though but not not a
cannabis gummy bear yeah
yeah
that kind of does make sense a little
bit if you're thinking about the kids
that's crazy but like most gummies look
like kid-friendly like you want to eat
them anyway even if they're not cheap
well i want to know what colorado
gummies look like if it makes it look
unfun yeah that's true if they don't
have cbd it could be yeah yeah yeah yeah
like the cbd gummies i want to see if it
looks like sad oh
i get their point it's like what if
you're high and you leave that [ __ ]
around the house and your [ __ ] kid
goes right there
what what should it look like that would
deter a child
but i thought that's [ __ ]
wouldn't that be up to the store like
you just don't carry those gummies at
like a target or something right you
just get them at like a dispensary well
they just wouldn't yeah they just can't
be sold so i guess like you wouldn't be
able to do any kind of inventory deal
with anybody because you know it's like
you know things out here you can't
legally sell them but you can have them
yeah yeah you know like car mods and
[ __ ] like you can't or like parts
yeah yeah butterfly knife yeah display
yeah but that's that's a reason they
think uh it falls under that degree of
like oh that's a human-shaped thing
yeah which is kind of a shame because
it's kind of you know so it's so good
yeah it's hilarious kid though did you
look at a gummy and go ooh that's an
elbow
kids now wouldn't even know the context
like that [ __ ] so long ago like we were
kids basically when that happened yeah
so it's like adults are gonna really
want that inside joke to have that gummy
but
sorry colorado oh just in colorado right
so yeah just colorado
everywhere else oh they're pro ear gummy
pro heaters pro your gummy what is your
guys favorite gummy
oh my goodness
what charlie eggs charlie eggs
oh
what the hell is that gummy worms but
the eggs bro the dinosaur egg trolley
i've never seen that [ __ ] oh truly oh
okay i remember that brand yeah i like
those um what are those japanese ones
where it's like individually packed
hot dogs and hamburgers and [ __ ] those
oh yeah yeah yeah they're like circles
it's like grape or like peach oh
individually wrapped you know
no no not high chews no but they would
always be next to them though it's like
fruit gummies yeah it's fruit gummies
yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah those little
like strawberries i've seen that one
yeah it never had an like an english
name though it was just like a
symbol
it said like
candy candy
[Laughter]
you'll see a sign that says
those are good too the coca-cola bottle
ones are good
oh the coke bottles are bomb yeah
swedish fish i don't know if that counts
yeah it's a classic i think it's like
it's like this can't go wrong yeah
you know australian gummies
are completely different from ours
because they use different sugar
do you like them better i like them dude
yeah my girlfriend always complains that
they're not the same out here it's soft
it's a different texture i like them
when they're hard
like a gummy bear like your gummy's hard
your fries yeah i like yeah i like hard
like gummy bears like i hate soft gummy
bears
yeah i like them like chewy you like it
when you bite it and it looks white like
it's so old it's chocolate yes sometimes
yeah it's just like really old red vines
basically yeah we got a lot of beer for
you dude those are aged i i know i i
always grab them when i age
those i like them those are
great red
a5 red vines
i don't know why i'm jerky i like it
like
just chewy and hard you like a chew to
it yeah you like licorice i do
do
twizzlers i love twizzlers twizzler's a
chewy one it is a sweet tart ropes
oh those are fire hey fire got a good
alt kick those are delicious
candy
uh movie theaters
oh they got exclusive
no no it's a licorice on the outside the
inside has like this fruit filling it's
like it's white
have any of you guys do any of you guys
eat cbd gummies or uh or cannabis
sometimes i just yeah sometimes
sometimes what's the effect like like
what is it like uh you look like a stone
cbd guppies without thc oh cbd yeah what
does that do i don't know i don't
i feel like just more relaxed it just
chills you out chill yeah more
relaxation doesn't do [ __ ] to me yeah
no you know what i was like kidding i
just feel good when i was a kid i liked
i liked the um
gobstoppers right are those the ones
with the what's oh gushers oh yeah
filling inside where it's like like just
juice in there but now that i'm older
i'm like
man how long has that juice been sitting
in there
oh my that's got to be like it's
borderline expired or something yeah
that's true now you have all this logic
you know but as a kid i can't wait for
it to gush all over my mouth yeah it's
probably made of like pure preservatives
that it's like
yeah never thought about that for like
four months and it's still good i
thought gushers though was genius like
that's the perfect thing for a kid like
it's so weird enough and the and the
advertising marketing was perfect like
the [ __ ] heads remember they would
eat it and their head would turn to a
fruit and they would go whoa
or like a gum that comes in a tape yeah
yeah
and you're like oh i have six inches and
then just start put oh yeah i could do
the whole thing yeah yeah
it was great yeah that's so funny i mean
anything's better than remember big
league chew bigly
i used to play around with those all the
time dude yeah did you ever take up
smoking no my my family did though like
my uncles
inspired
look how cool he looked
check it out i'd roll him up with my
white shirt
is that our son i'd be packing my candy
cigarettes also let's go get some
cigarettes
they have a couple of these candy shops
and it's like it's like a it's like a
sweet factory like back in the day where
you could get all kinds of [ __ ] oh
yeah you feel like
they have everything right
and they have all those throwback
candies like they have a [ __ ] barrel
full of like cigarette gummies all that
[ __ ] and i was like what the [ __ ] i
thought the bandies dude like the cigar
ones
yeah the cigar ones there was like
bubble gum i think we knew how far they
actually tried to go and then they went
nah let's see like
candy i want to see the real life
remember raven's revenge yes dude what
is that sounds full from it it was the
powders dude i like powder and you can
pick the powder and you put it in a tube
and then you would like it was like
green apple and it was like it was
literally like powder and then you just
like a pixie stix kind of sort of like
pixie sticks but then
some kids were doing that we're doing
that with sweet tarts remember like the
no no smarties smarties i knew kids i
need some degenerates who would like
crush it up and then like to [ __ ] around
oh yeah you guys won't try this i don't
know what my parents do all the time
mom and dad and they're like
putting on their teeth and everything
it was like a three pack thing and then
you could really yeah dip it sticks oh
yeah yeah
i just made up a name [ __ ] sticks
dipping
[Laughter]
did you guys ever have that one where
it's like wax paper and there's just
dots on it with like yellow or blue
that's some old-timey candy i've seen it
i've seen that what does it taste like i
don't know i was wondering if you guys
tasted sounds so abstract like our
parents are just making just like yeah
oh it's deconstructed
candy artisanal cake
what about like white rabbit candies
white rabbits where you can eat the
paper yeah oh
it's about the asian candy asian candy
yeah yeah those are bomb those are they
have those rice chew things it's like
it's like green and it's like um it's
it's a japanese one it looks like it's
made in like world war one and [ __ ] and
there's like a [ __ ] fat baby on the
cover and then when you open it up
there's like a it's wrapped in rice
paper but it's like an orange chewy rice
candy mmm no that sounds bomb
that's asian too oh that's japanese and
that's when i think i know you're
talking about that's like that's like
you almost break your teeth on it yeah
but they were so good though they were
fire i used to sneak in my ground legs
though you want to go through
ha ha
they're number one so many good asian
kids aren't even made out of i don't
know what it was like
it's it's is it no no it's made out of
spare something
spare tire gotta be like something that
they didn't use and they're like
it's delicious you look like a [ __ ]
dynamite dude yeah yeah yeah
you rip it open you would take a whole
stack of them to try to bite it the
perfect bite yes you know what would
have been really cool if back in the day
there was an asian ice cream truck that
had all these like asian candies
you know that i should check out all the
mexican bomb ass weird candies that
everybody like knew but there was never
like an asian dude that's actually
pretty cool like if someone made that
right now that actually
vw bus
[Music]